Chimps are brutal creatures,
man,
like they go to war a and so if you have
a chimp territory out in the jungle,
then the the juveniles will,
the males in particular,
the band together in groups of four or
five.
There's often but not always a female or
two with them,
and if they come across chimps from
another troupe that aren't within their
hierarchy,
let's say they will,
if they're,
if they outnumber them because they
can't really count,
but they can estimate magnitude
visually.
It's not the same as counting,
but if they outnumber them,
they will tear them to pieces and chimps
or at least twice as strong as a really
well developed human male.
And so they can tear you up pretty good.
And chimps are perfectly capable.
They hunt,
they're carnivorous like human beings
and they hunt,
they hunt,
call a monkeys often they weigh about 40
pounds and they'll basically eat them
alive.
A monkey screaming away like mad because
you know,
it's in pain because it's being eaten.
And um,
that doesn't slow the chimps down a bit.
There's no cross species empathy
stopping them from having their snack.
And so,
chimps are very brutal creatures and uh,
it isn't obvious they have a lot of
internal inhibition of their aggression
at all.
Most of the inhibition is sociological,
it's out in the hierarchy.
And so the reason chimps aren't always
aggressive with one another is because
they know who can pound them and,
and who will gang up on them and who
won't be established their hierarchy
anyways.
You know,
you think about a champ hierarchy and
you're talking about a fairly strong and
aggressive creature.
You might think it's biggest,
ugliest,
meanest,
most vicious,
irritable,
unpleasant chimp that rises to the top.
We're all,
that's kind of the postmodernist view of
human society.
But that's not the case.
It happens sometimes.
But what happens in dwell has documented
this quite nicely,
is that tyron chimps lead unstable
regimes.
Now,
you know,
that might sound familiar because the
same thing of course is true human
beings.
And why is that?
Well,
it's because you know,
people don't like tyrants and chimps
don't like them that much either.
And chimps are actually quite reciprocal
in their social interactions.
So they don't just dominate each other,
they groom each other,
they have friendships,
they can track social relationships over
very long periods of time now and they
do that and so they engage in reciprocal
interactions,
let's say prosocial reciprocal
interactions and you might think,
well what's the,
what's the weak point of the biggest,
ugliest,
toughest chimp in the troop?
And that is he doesn't have any friends.
And so,
you know,
maybe as a bad day is a little hung over
or whatever for eating fermented bananas
or whatever he is partying with and to
have the slightly less ugly,
less slightly less mean.
Chimps decide,
well this is a good time to take them
out and they tear him to pieces.
And so one of the things to Wallace
pointed out quite nicely is that if you
want to have a stable chimp dominance
hierarchy,
let's call it a regime,
the stable ones aren't ruled by the
tyrants because tyrants get taken out
by,
by paired up friendship dyads,
something like that.
So that's really worth thinking about
too,
you know,
because
because it indicates that even in
creatures that have less complex
sociological orders and they do because
one of the things that predicts how
complex your social order is,
how big your brain is compared to your
body,
it's encephalization essentially,
and the more encephalitis to creature,
the larger the social groups that
contract.
And of course human beings are very
highly encephalitis.
So we have quite complicated group,
um,
we have quite complicated group
organizations,
but even in simpler group organizations
like the chimps,
it isn't the tyrant who rule stable and
that turns out to be also incredibly
important.
Okay.
So,
so,
so much for the idea that power is the
only game in town.
Then you got to ask.
The question is,
well,
this is actually a postmodern question.
So you know,
one of the things Dennis said that the
main postmodern joker is that by
categorizing you,
you,
you privilege one concept and you pray,
you force other concepts out to the
margins.
And so he believed that when you
construct it a hierarchy of power,
that the hierarchy of power,
privilege certain people and
marginalized others,
and you know that's really not that
brilliant and observation as far as I'm
concerned,
it's rather commonplace.
All it means is that when you categorize
something that there are things that are
in the category and a bunch of things
that aren't and so you actually can't
categorize anything,
which meant means you can't perceive
anything,
which means you can't think or live
without making some things in the middle
and everything else on the outside,
it's.
It's part of categorization itself.
And so maybe the postmodernist would go
far enough to question the utility of
categorization itself.
And I think to some degree they do do
that.
But I'm the point here is that if you.
You have to ask why it is that you
would,
if you were a postmodernist yourself,
why it is that you would privilege the
idea of power above all else.
So exactly what is it that you're
pushing to the margin.
And so that's something that we're going
to talk about.
Now,
here's one thing you might push to the
margin.
Let's say that you believe that
hierarchies are a consequence of power.
Well then you push competence to the
margin and then applying the postmodern
modernist logic.
You might say,
well,
the reason you're privileging power is
so that you can produce so that you
could push competence to the margin,
and so you want to keep that in mind
too,
because that's going to become important
as we discussed the relationship between
postmodernism and Marxism.
Maybe you're after the destruction of
the idea competence itself.
All right,
so
froggy postmoderns and we talked about
it a little bit.
We'll return to it.
Now we're going to talk a little bit
about Marxism.
I've got a quote here from mark's.
The proletarians have nothing to lose,
but our chains.
Well,
I was pretty good for like 1880 or 1890
or whenever it was he wrote at somewhere
around that period of time it turned out
the proletarians had a lot more to lose
than their chains.
They had their lives and their families
to lose.
That was demonstrated and play as a
consequence of the.
What would you call it,
the sociological movements that were put
into place when the Marxist
presuppositions began to govern
societies like the Soviet Union.
So,
all right,
so let's take the same postmodernist
approach.
So here's some basic tenants of Marxism.
It's Berge Lousy against proletariat.
The bridge was the year,
the capitalists,
the property owners,
those sorts of people,
the proletariat,
the working class,
for all intents and purposes.
The basic idea is that history itself is
nothing but the,
what would you call it,
the documentation of the struggle of one
class against the other.
Um,
okay.
no,
like,
that's wrong,
but it's okay because it's too simple.
Obviously.
It's obviously too simple.
There's all sorts of motivations that
people have.
Some of them are economic,
some of them are associated with power.
Um,
but that's okay.
We will leave that.
Let's,
let's give the devil his due and say,
well,
yeah,
fair enough.
There's still a fair bit of tension
between the haves and the haves and have
nots.
And maybe that was even more intense in
previous societies than it is now.
And it's no,
there's no doubt that economics plays a
role in,
in virtually everything that human
beings do in a fairly significant role.
So let,
let's,
let's accept that as a
potential theory.
It's,
it's simple,
but maybe it's
practically useful.
And then there's kind of an offshoot of
that theory,
which is that,
well,
if you're a Marxist,
that means you have sympathy for the
working class,
right?
Because that's what you're saying all
the time.
It's like,
well,
the poor working class,
they're all oppressed.
The poor,
poor proletariat,
you know?
And,
and then you're also saying,
well we're the good guys because we're
standing on the side of the oppressed.
And so then you might also ask what
you're marginalizing when you claim that
you're the good guys because one of the
things that you would be marginalizing
is all of the ways in which you're not
the good guys,
but we can leave that aside for a moment
too.
So,
but there's the claims is that,
you know,
there's the working class against the
ruling class.
Another claim is the ruling class is the
ruined class because they exploited the
working class,
basically stealing their excess labor
from them.
Um,
another very,
very,
you're a what,
a surfacely attractive claim that lacks
any reasonable justification because
it's predicated on the idea of the world
as a zero sum game.
And clearly the world is not a zero sum
game.
So when someone creates wealth,
when someone is wealthy,
it can be at least at times because they
created it,
not because they swiped it from someone
else.
I think,
you know,
you can think of someone like Bill Gates
or Steve Jobs is a good example of that.
Um,
you know,
they're,
they're what they produced had a value
that far exceeded what they garnered as
a consequence of their production even
though what they garnered was fairly
substantial.
So anyways,
but we'll get,
like you said,
we're going to give the devil his due.
Okay.
It's the bourgeoisie against the
proletariat will accept that.
It's class warfare is the primary
historical mover.
No problem.
Now,
but here's what I'm not willing to give
away so easily.
Uh,
we have sympathy for the working class
primarily and we're good because of
that.
No,
I'm not gonna like,
give that away.
So simply.
So let's investigate that a little bit.
Let's see if we can actually figure it
out.
If that's true,
we'll say a use a pragmatic approach
because I'm a pragmatist in that William
James,
Sansa,
uh,
or maybe you can think about it even
more deeply in anciently.
Uh,
there's a statement in the New
Testament,
I think it's by their fruits,
you shall know the fine.
So we're going to walk down that road,
um,
before we do that.
So now that's another thing you have to
keep in mind.
Before we do that,
I want to make one more detour.
Okay.
So I like making detours and then
tangling all back together.